it's been nearly a year since Russia
invaded Ukraine president veloda
mirzolinski is now seeking more weapons
and hoping to join the European Union
but what can EU membership offer this is
Inside Story
[Music]
hello and welcome to the program I'm
Muhammad for the first time since Russia
invaded Ukraine nearly a year ago
president Valor mirzolinski has been
able to tour Europe he's using the
opportunity to thank European leaders
for their support but has also doubled
down on his request for more military
assistance zielinski is also seeking an
expedited process to join the EU he says
ukrainians are fighting on behalf of all
Europe and has warned against an
impending Russian offensive we'll get to
our guests in a moment but first this
update from our diplomatic editor James
bays in Brussels
on the third stage of his brief surprise
European tour after trips to London and
Paris president zielinski flew with the
French President Emmanuel macron to
Brussels
[Music]
in the capital of the European Union he
was again repeating the same message
thanks for all your help but Ukraine
still needs more
he told the PAC session of the European
Parliament that Ukraine's home in the
future is as part of Europe
we are moving closer to the European
Union Ukraine will be a member of the
European Union Ukraine that is winning
will be a member of the European Union
that is winning
after standing ovations in the
parliament a short drive away he was
again greeted with Applause by the
leaders of all the eu's 27 Nations
when he sat down with them he laid out
his specific requests
we need artillery guns ammunitions
modern tanks long-range missiles modern
aircraft at a news conference president
zielinski wouldn't detail the responses
he's received to his wish list but he
said the conversations have been
constructive he also stressed that time
is critical with the new Russian
offensive expected in the coming weeks
James Bays Al Jazeera Brussels
all right let's go ahead and bring in
our guests in Kiev sarahisha pavalov is
a political analyst at the ilco chair of
democratic initiatives Foundation
in Messina Italy Daniela Herrera
professor of international relations at
the University of Catania and in
Washington DC Samuel green director of
the democratic resilience program at the
center for European policy analysis a
warm welcome to you all and thanks so
much for joining us today on Inside
Story uh Sarah let me start with you
today Russia launched a new wave of
missiles across Ukraine in the last
several hours what's the current
situation for you right now in Kiev
the situation
um is okay it is not the first wave of
Russia missile attacks
they are trying to
Target our energy infrastructure so they
aim May in the civilian population they
try to
um
turn off the electricity for us but as
you can see I am with you I have
internet and everything so Russia fails
another time uh to harm our civilian
population and most of their Rockets
were intercepted our general staff
reported that 61 out of 71 uh Cruz
missile was shot down uh this morning
and it is sent to our air defense and
thanks to our partners who provide
Ukraine with Advanced uh air defense
systems
um maybe it was a nervous Russian
reaction to these meetings of the landsc
teams EU leaders and British prime
minister but we are totally okay all
right Sherry let me turn now to um the
topic of that trip by President
zielinski how significant was the trip
and how important was it that president
zielinski was able to meet face to face
with all these EU leaders at the same
time
well the main uh the main topic of the
lenky zelensky uh meetings with both
British prime minister and EU leaders uh
was to provide Ukraine with the weapons
that Ukraine needs to repel Russian
aggression and to liberate Ukrainian
territories in particular it was about
F-16 uh fighter jets which are complex
and expensive weapons these meetings are
an important step in their negotiation
process and uh without these meetings a
political decision to provide Ukraine
with fighter jets uh cannot be made
similar negotiations have been going on
for a long time regarding other weapon
systems
uh through diplomatic efforts Ukraine
convinced its Partners to expand
military assistance and provide Ukraine
with new and more powerful systems it
was about Highmark systems uh Patriot
air defense system uh western town
Western tanks such as leopard two
Challenger to Abrams Etc so firstly
political decisions should be made to
transfer these weapons to Ukraine and
these meetings uh are important because
in making such decisions
um the emotional aspect and personal
trust play an important role uh and such
meetings allow for this personal contact
between and personal trust between
European leaders and volodimer's
Landscape Dania if you remember
sorry sir go ahead
foreign yeah if you remember Ukraine was
granted um EU candidate statues after uh
EU leaders in particular Schultz and
macron visited Ukraine uh and they
witnessed the consequences of Russian
war crimes and this involves these um
emotional aspect and it makes such a
decisions about granting eucated status
or providing Ukraine with weapons easier
so this is why it is important Daniela
uh you heard there as early talking
about the fact that president zelinski
is seeking more weapons more weapon
systems from EU leaders uh presidents
Lindsay also said at the conclusion of
those meetings that several European
leaders had expressed to him their
Readiness to supply Kiev with fighter
jets I want to get your perspective on
How likely you think that might be to
happen
um well these are very very important
and relevant knitting because For the
First Time In president Celestia had the
chance to meet the the European leaders
please let me remind that there's a long
uh and established relation uh between
the EU and Ukraine that until the
Ukraine has been part of the European
abroad policy and also the U.S try to
play an important role already in in
2014 and in 2017.
um but so let's get also always looked
at the EU and the European countries but
we also have to remind uh and to remain
remember that European countries have
different preferences when it comes to
foreign policy bilateral relations
defense policies
um so this means that uh the uh the
presidential scheme was looking at the
EU but yes also very relevant bilateral
relations with some of the European
countries so this can make the
difference obviously meeting the U as a
whole this time
can be a symbolic different thing but at
the same time because there's more
formal legitimization and it is clear
that yes the president has prioritized
those countries which have always
supported more than others Ukraine so
obviously France and UK but at the same
time we have to remember that different
preferences and intergovernmental
priorities may play a significant role
in it and Daniella just to go back for a
moment to the issue of the fighter jets
because president zielinski did say that
you know private conversations he had
with these leaders at least led him to
believe that they might be willing to
send a military aircraft or fighter jets
to Ukraine going forward
um from your Vantage Point do you think
that is something that is more like
likely to be considered Now by EU
leaders than it was in the past
uh well it's hard to say hard to predict
because it's strictly connected to what
they've just said that you know
different priorities Ethiopian countries
may have in Principle as I was saying
before this is more than a symbolic
meeting so uh Celestia could expect more
support or more Military Support but I
just heard uh this morning that at the
end of the meeting uh at some
political leaders who are a little bit
cautious like president macron was a bit
more cautious than in uh yesterday for
example so this may we can say that in
principle in May uh be likely to happen
more than in the past because this
meeting can make a difference but at the
same time we always have to remember
that the intergovernmental Dimension is
a is a strong constraint for European
countries so it's very hard to predict
uh Sam Russia has said that if countries
were to send fighter jets to Ukraine
that that would have ramifications for
the whole world this is rhetoric that
we've heard in the past from President
Putin and members of his administration
but in this scenario if that were to
actually happen if countries were to
consider sending Jets or were to
actually send Jets going forward what
would it mean when it comes to Russia
and what would Russia be prepared to do
well if the only person who really knows
the answer to that question is letting
her Putin and his incentive of course is
to keep us guessing uh and to make us
think right um uh to that um that we
should be in fact deterring ourselves uh
from uh from supporting Ukraine
um the reality is we're now about a year
into this war
um and uh Putin has tried and and his
his uh spokespeople have tried at
various points to draw uh various red
lines any sort of military support any
sort of economic support for Ukraine um
was initially positioned as something
that could lead to a a an expansion of
the uh of the war
um uh any you know provision of of of
military support in terms of of uh
anti-aircraft systems uh then in terms
of artillery systems and then in terms
of of tanks and what we've seen is that
at each stage
um you know Russia really has not uh uh
you know followed through uh with some
of these threats um and we have seen
again a Ukrainian military that that is
are capable and resilient to Ukrainian
State and Ukrainian society that are
capable and resilience as well as the
growing uh recognition uh in in Western
capitals uh that um you know this is not
a war uh that we can afford to allow
um uh Russia to win it will create a
world
um in which we don't really uh want to
live and so well I think Daniela is
right that there are differences of
opinion about exactly how to achieve
that Victory uh uh for Ukraine I think
we're seeing an increasing
sense of confidence uh from Western
leaders
um that they can and should continue uh
to support Ukraine in ways that will
allow them to manage those risks
um but that also there's a an
opportunity here to shift uh uh the
logic a bit right so the tanks um that
so he was mentioning a a moment ago you
know will will show up on Ukrainian
battlefields only uh in a matter of
months uh to be honest it takes time to
train people to to get things shipped to
get things uh uh positioned to get the
supply lines in place the same will be
true uh uh for uh for fighter jets when
uh those are uh eventually approved and
I do think it is a question of when
rather than uh rather than if but what
we've seen particularly with the
announcement from London that Britain
would begin to train uh uh Ukrainian Air
Force pilots what that does is it
shortens the delivery time right so uh
once we get to the point right uh where
uh a political decision is made uh to
deliver these aircraft uh they will be
able to get into the fight much much
quicker and that doesn't just change the
dynamic on the battlefield that changes
the calculations obviously for zelenski
it means that he can afford uh to keep
taking the fight to Russia but it
changes the calculation for Russia uh as
well Putin has been hoping throughout
this that he will eventually reach a
point that we will eventually reach a
point at which Western capitals are no
longer willing to provide uh support for
uh for Ukraine and what these meetings
and these commitments continue to show
him uh is that that point uh will not
come until such time as Russia has lost
this war Sam let me pick up on a point
you were making and ask you something
about it uh you were talking about the
logistics of all this you were talking
about supply lines um you know there are
a lot of analysts that believe that
Russia is on the verge of launching a
new large-scale offensive in Ukraine
perhaps in the next few weeks but one of
the complicating factors here is the
fact that when the ground begins to thaw
mud is going to be an obstacle so are
Russian troops actually in a position to
advance at this stage
it's very hard to know right um we don't
exactly know what they're planning
obviously uh and and I myself I'm not a
military analyst so I I listen to the
smart people on this I think what the
the consensus among the smart people on
this is right uh is that uh it's going
to be a difficult couple of months um uh
the ukrainians themselves have been very
clear about the fact that they are
facing uh a Russian military that has uh
increased its Manpower uh along the
front lines particularly in in the East
um that uh does seem to be looking to
make progress not you know uh Galloping
progress across Ukraine um but uh uh to
make you know uh uh uh marginal gains
um uh they are also willing to uh take
very significant losses in terms of
Manpower and Equipment uh in order to do
that
um and uh in an effort I think to
exhaust Ukraine and exhaust uh the West
so again this communication that uh uh
that Ukraine will not run out of support
from the West that uh there is more
Firepower coming to the front line that
Ukraine will be able to withstand uh
this uh renewed assault from Russia and
will be in a position to uh to
counter-attack uh is extremely important
to the calculations on both sides
Daniella obviously right now we're
seeing a unified EU that is bolstering
its support to Ukraine but if the war
continues to grind on if it essentially
becomes a war of attrition would at some
point we see EU countries push to get
Ukraine and Russia to the negotiating
table
uh well this is very hard as well
because the EU has already lived other
crisis and uh already demonstrated very
little ability to to produce significant
results in the Diplomatic scale
um for sure uh while it was it was told
that during the meeting is that the
fight
for uh for uh for Ukraine is also fight
for uh the so-called EU values so
democracy Freedom civilization and and
so on and this is what have been said
today until until today and it was
basically a symbolic uh support
um what will happen in the future uh let
me remind what happened in 2017 and 2018
with the the Minsk agreement where the
EU was was expected to play a major role
and in the end it was very very
difficult and then the situation
remained a little bit uh unbalanced for
uh for a little while and then uh
prolonged until today so it is very hard
for you to find a common position this
would be the basic condition to have a
common position and until until now we
have seen this common position is very
difficult when it comes to weapon
provision uh when it comes also to
relations among states as for energy
dependencies of Germany for example or
other countries in in the eastern part
of Europe at different views compared to
other countries in the western part of
Europe
um so what is missing is a common ground
on which all member states can can act
so probably we may expect some
initiatives some efforts on the part of
probably EU institutions a commission
the commission for example but um
it is very hard to say that the EU will
play a decisive role I would say again
sir he if things get to a point I know
we're not at that stage right now but if
things were to get to a point where the
EU or the us or the EU and the US were
to try to apply pressure on president
zielinski to get him to the negotiating
table with Russia when it comes to
potential negotiations with Russia where
does public opinion in Ukraine stand on
this
uh in December a month ago the
organization that I represent Democratic
initiative Foundation we conducted a
national Nationwide survey that showed
that 62 percent of ukrainians uh do not
accept any compromises with their
occupiers another 18 of ukrainians
believe that some compromises can be
made but not all compromises this means
that it is uh possible to negotiate on
humanitarian issues such as return of
prisoners of War uh but
not political compromises or territorial
concessions and only about eight percent
of ukrainians are ready to make white
compromises including political ones and
as we can see the vast majority of
ukrainians
uh belief uh they um ukrainians
understand that Russia intends to
completely destroy our country and our
people uh the war crimes that they
commit every day selling peaceful cities
and killing civilians executing people
in the occupied territories these acts
uh can be clearly called genocide
therefore there is no room for
compromise ukrainians Want to Be Free
People and Russia wants to kill us uh we
have nothing to negotiate about we will
continue our uh the fight for our
freedom and liberate our territory from
the occupiers we have both determination
and their resources to do so and uh
about the behavior of our partners I
don't believe that they will start
pushing Ukraine uh for compromises I
think that macron and German leaders
who previously in the previous years
maybe they believed that Putin is
negotiatable but now they see that Putin
is non-negotiatable and he continues
this War uh and there is no way other
than to strengthen Ukraine and force
Putin to stop this war maybe uh these
those negotiations
um about uh tanks and public statements
about tanks were such a kind of signal
or sign for Putin
um I'll try explain my thoughts for
example uh Americans and European
leaders say that we may provide Ukraine
with standards at such a public
statement is a sign for pujin that
either you are stopping this war now or
we provide Ukraine with everything
needed to just expel you from the
territory of Ukraine you will be
military defeated in military terms uh
Putin didn't accept this sign and it
means that he is non-negotiable he
doesn't perceive such
not direct communication but
communication with such public
statements sorry I'm sorry I'm sorry
that is why this is why the decision was
made to give a standards sure sure yeah
I'm sorry to interrupt you but we are
starting to run out of time I just want
to ask a few more questions uh to Sam
and Daniella uh Sam um last month
President Putin replaced his top
commander in Ukraine yet again that's
the third time that's happened in less
than a year uh will the appointment of
Valerie garasimov make a difference or
is there any indication that it could
make a difference
oh I don't think it is I'm gonna think
what we've seen since then has been a a
doubling down on the strategy uh that so
he was talking about right from the very
beginning of this
um of this conversation right and that
we've seen since uh September October of
last year uh when Russia started these
waves of
um of of bombardments uh on Ukrainian
civilians and civilian infrastructure
designed to uh to exhaust the country it
has failed uh to do that they have
um you know brought to fruition the plan
for a partial mobilization at least that
will put some more manpower and they
will test the front line um but at the
end of the day uh you know moving
generals around and changing the chain
of command does not give uh Russia new
technology it does not give Russia uh
new armaments it doesn't really change
the situation on the battlefield it
doesn't give Russia a new military uh
with which to fight or fundamentally a
new strategy the reality is that Russia
has picked a war picked a fight that it
uh it can't really win
um and
um and the initiative does really remain
on the on the western side and there's
there's nothing that
um uh that puts really can do about that
Daniella in the past
um in in video streamed addresses uh to
EU meetings and to to EU leaders uh
president zielinski has been critical at
times of of some of the European
countries that he believed weren't doing
enough to help Ukraine
um was his tone in in his address during
this tour different was it more
diplomatic what was he trying to show
his appreciation more this time around
yeah that was completely different uh I
mean the tone was more diplomatic but at
the same time I would say it was more
strategic but probably because AAS
perceived that this this meeting was not
going to be uh symbolic uh only symbolic
because it was uh he was being very much
symbolic too much symbolic until now for
things that definitely going to be to be
different uh it is true that there were
some countries from European countries
you members that in the past have
demonstrated to be not so much
supportive as the others in respect to
Trudeau to Ukraine uh but at the same
time what we saw during this meeting was
a more let's say comprehensive approach
to what Ukraine obviously some countries
I don't know like Hungary for example
didn't
demonstrate a complete complete new uh
approach but in some way with ways it
was a little bit more
was here for expecting a bit more and
probably it was it was using a more
strategic approach cautious approach
digit ones well
um sir he uh we only have a couple of
minutes left uh I want to ask you when
it comes to president zielinski trying
to ensure that Ukraine can join the EU
do you think that Ukraine will be able
to join the EU in an expedited Manner
and and also more importantly what can
EU membership offer Ukraine
the EU membership is a
long-term Advantage for Ukraine uh it
will allow Ukraine to restore after the
after all the devastations made by
Russia and um
this was this will also help to make our
country better because in order to
become
um a EU member State Ukraine uh needs to
make reforms or otherwise Ukraine
doesn't become EU member State and um
such reforms
they will not allow such things like
corruption or mismanagement that were
widespread in Ukraine before I think
that the EU membership will allow us to
become better internally and in future
we will live without such such things
like corruption that ruined us and
because of corruption the money are
spent ineffective in an effective way
sorry I'm sorry to interrupt you again
we're just almost out of time just very
quickly do you think that the EU will
allow Ukraine to join anytime soon just
very quickly please
it will not happen until the war ends I
suppose and I think it can take up to
five or seven years
uh when such reforms that are needed for
Ukraine to join EU
it will it will make this possible
all right we have run out of time so
we're gonna have to leave the
conversation there thanks so much to all
of our guests
Daniela Herrera and Samuel green
and thank you two for watching you can
see the program again anytime by
visiting our website aljazeera.com and
for further discussion go to our
Facebook page that's facebook.com
forward slash AJ Inside Story you can
also join the conversation on Twitter
our handle is at AJ Inside Story for me
Mohammad the whole team here bye for now
foreign